today hollywood is mourning the sudden
loss of actor ray liotta the prolific
star of films like field of dreams and
goodfellas has died at just 67 years old
while shooting a movie in the dominican
republic jamie yuka shows us what made
leota so unforgettable
in his most memorable performance ray
liotta shined as mobster henry hill in
martin scorsese's classic goodfellas
as macho and menacing as he was on
screen
if you touch her again you're dead leota
claimed it was all for the camera i've
never been in a fight my whole life
in this 1990 interview leota described
what led up to goodfellas people would
ask me who who would you let you know
what directors would you like to work
with what actors
and
was martin scorsese at the top of the
list as a director and robert de niro as
an actor in a statement scorsese said he
absolutely amazed me and i'll always be
proud of the work we did together
you got some nerve standing mia nobody
does that to me former co-star lorraine
bronco tweeted i am utterly shattered
leota was adopted at six months old from
an orphanage in newark new jersey don't
shut me out ray he would develop into
one of the most prolific actors of his
time
a year before goodfellas leota starred
as the ghost of a baseball legend in
field of dreams
leota would later earn an emmy for a
guest starring role on er
i'm here for a good reason you don't
need to help me he was in the middle of
a career resurgence with films like the
many saints of newark
leota leaves behind his daughter carson
and his fiancee j.c natollo whom he
called the love of my life
where's he going
i don't know
for cbs morning's jamie yukis in los
angeles
he lives on in those films he will live
on forever in those he was such a great
actor and he played a bad guy very well
and his daughter said he was nothing at
all like that i saw an interview there's
been a lot of interviews with him lately
running and he said he always wanted to
play the romantic lead where he could
kiss the girl and not choke her out
that would be nice yeah that would be
nice to see yeah he will be missed he's
left behind quite a treasure for all of